this week we've got foot watching baby
shark and viral goats foot watching huh
yeah so forefoot watching
is it the foot fetish Olympic fetish
thing no it's actually that really
disgusting video of an airline passenger
using oh [ __ ] this fall this is so gross
won't kept sending this [ __ ] to me
saying this is me [ __ ] this [ __ ]
disgusting person this is really fun
well maybe they don't want to touch it
because there's good of all the bacteria
on the screen that I don't want to put
on their hands they have that reasons
but they're [ __ ] disgusting I'm just
trying to play devil's advocate good
love life and what could be the reason
sometimes things are so obscene I just
want to punch them cuz you see something
like that happen like if I was a flight
attendant right like if it's like
something weird you're like oh excuse me
please not do that sir but then when you
see that it's so far gone or just like
Shh punch um I don't even know how to
explain that
like cuz where do I start you know can
you please not do that sir and then he's
like I would be a little racist what's
he mainland Chinese yes he was they look
like some Chinese feet he looks like
Chinese feet Chinese /home but it would
agents do this though cuz they're so
like mainland Chinese how do you female
a [ __ ]
you know I have not they take a dump in
public on the floor I heard I don't know
who this person is
I could tell by there's midnight Chinese
mainland Chinese Chinese classes and
mainland Chinese haircut it's funny just
because you know the taking shoes off
and it like the feet cleanliness is such
a thing for Asians so if it is transport
that's very I don't think mail a Chinese
fit in the description of Asia of
regular Asians now there's something
else oh yeah yeah so a crime novelist a
New York Times bestselling author and it
takes kung-fu to do that that's true
that's come from you guys you try to
swipe try to swipe some [ __ ] with your
toe go
I could do it if you're a dancer you
could probably do it oh happy quick
follow-up video we should you toe pad
and see if we could do it I want to do
that because I have so many blisters on
my feet it helps the calluses this
author she was the one that tweeted this
out with the caption my friend who
doesn't have Twitter sent this from her
flight it belongs on Twitter and then it
got viewed more than like 6 million oh
[ __ ] and then that's disgusting
yeah so then it was funny because she
ended up tweeting with the follow up
y'all my nephew texted me and says he
thinks this will start a trend now I
hate everything wait like everyone's
doing this job because they saw it who
do you know like you know big world I
like the foot challenge something I
think oh yeah turns into a meme and
wants to do it what about if he had foot
wipes and then after he was done he
wiped the thing down me I know someone
actually thought maybe he had a
disability or like you know that's what
I first thought he didn't have no arm he
didn't have something but then the
friend confirmed that no that was not
the case because you guys she saw him
walk on and off the plane and carrying
his own bag but would it be different
than if he did have a disability and
didn't have a different way different no
other options still the cleanliness part
cuz what's disgusting everyone right now
or what's what they had other options
it's like okay if you have your arms and
your feet and this one has a boner and
he's swiping with his dick it's like why
but if you had no arms no legs you have
to use his boner oh no no - I'm like ok
you could use your dick go ahead so then
it's an options things it's not a
sanitary thing for you I think it's
definitely a sanitary thing - of I mean
obviously for sure but if he didn't have
his hands options it's more
understandable only using his feet I
would assume that he has like he would
clean it afterward but what if he was
tired he was hit him like it he was so
tired he couldn't use his Hawaii he
couldn't go like this he had to use his
feet sometimes I pet my cat with my feet
me too because I'm like you're too far
I'm a reserve my judgment until I know
what movie he watched skyscraper
actually does it a lot because there was
a lot of grace it's choppy like clean
lines okay no that doesn't look like
Asian feet man I told you he's good he's
really good Delta flight is that a delta
feels wrong yeah I think that the Delta
I wish shall we leave he has his arms
you can feel our maybe those are Z but
what if they're nubs
maybe he does it for fun like he on
Instagram he's one of those people that
like paints with his toes they like
that's his big Oh cuz there's people
like that that they're just in a weird
shape but they do it in private so if
you saw this guy he sat down he had foot
wipes he wiped it all down nice and
clean and he started doing that would
you be okay with that no cuz I was just
being like you lazy [ __ ] be like
the rest of us [ __ ] you it's actually
not it's arguably harder to do your
hands are probably dirtier than your
feet cuz you're touching every smell
like my feet and my feet doesn't touch
my dick
that's another truth I think it's the
public perception of it because if you
went and shook someone's hand right like
hey nice to meet you and they stuck
their foot out to you like this is clean
know you blame mother yeah this is my
foot here we go like this glad you know
what caused the fight cuz it's a cup
there's a certain percentage a respect
thing yeah so I think like with that no
matter how clean it is it just looks
like he's dissing the whole airline
because I want to do that one day
there Amelia that Charlie Murphy sketch
right he's like got mud on his feet and
his yoke out what if he had you know how
there's gloves I can use the touchscreen
what if you had socks that had that
would that be like he put on extra socks
like foot con baby everyone's just like
if you have hands yeah refuse your hands
sure but I wonder if people would be
just as outraged yeah don't
got those remotes too so you can
technically use a variety oh [ __ ] I
didn't even think about that moving on
to the next story a city in Florida they
have launched a new plan to play kids
songs like baby shark and raining tacos
on a continuous overnight loop to keep
the city's homeless from sleeping in
this like patio area that that's fun
because homeless people hate those songs
they're just trying to like to annoy
them crazy to annoy them but they're
already crazy though they don't know
homeless people you think that's gonna
bother them [ __ ] that that's not gonna
bark have you heard baby shark 100 times
in five minutes I could use earplugs
girl but you're seeing Jose right a lot
of these people like legislators they're
thinking from a normal person psychology
they don't know crazy people and then
they could just get newspapers and make
paper mache ear plugs and a [ __ ] lot
asleep that's exactly what people are
saying you think they can get your plug
yeah where you believe they're just
gonna pick up the [ __ ] off the floor and
then make it [ __ ] earplugs in their
ears you know this is like a child
coming up with a robbery they're like
we're gonna go in there with that
eyeglasses a nose thing and no one's
gonna [ __ ] suspect anything also I
feel bad for the the writers of these
songs now they're like wait what like
that was a torture tactic I think that
they used yes with Barney that oh god we
like it was usual for interrogators at
Guantanamo Bay Oh did it work just
waterboard me instead I hate this song
they raise their kids and then PBS comes
on and say I love you like PTSD I'll be
dope but they start singing too anything
dami we can't weed
but yeah so they're saying that this
place they it's like a temporary thing
because they're trying to figure out a
different way of like implementing
actual like times that people can't be
there but they're trying to say that
this whole thing is just a temporary
solution to try to keep people from
sleeping on the property and it's funny
because they did interview some homeless
people and they were like
I don't listen to it thank you this what
spikes on the floor and then like the
way they do with birds
yeah they don't let at night it's like
it's like yeah the [ __ ] nights come
out yeah people get at what at that like
when people see those all right like no
you homeless people like on the floor
like how inhumane it is inhumane for
sure but I was getting creative for
those people like okay then can five of
them sleep by your house Yeah right
exactly opened up here Yatta great
solutions yeah I think solutions yes
yeah that's true
or they could just put like soap and
water everywhere so they just slide the
whole time butter have you ever seen
that video that girl dancing on butter
no I've seen the one where they do the
exercise and they put soap and in there
just all the treadmills yeah she's like
running in place no this guy's trying to
do like a like really graceful ass hula
dance and she's on butter and she she
[ __ ] lighting all over but she keeps
doing it she's like why is she on but I
don't know there's so many questions
Google it Google bit I have a I have a
idea to solve this the homelessness
problem yeah so instead of being a dick
and going in there with the fire hose
and like wetting them down or anything
like that right okay but instead of
because I see the baby shark thing is
kind of like that it kind of [ __ ] up
like you just try to turn fire on and
let them let them burn or whatever but
in my solution it's let's let's help
them become like a like a member of
society and if they do something for the
park they could stay there for the night
but then you have to leave before
sunrise
I like their security they could be
secured yeah they could be security they
could be clear saying it's their same
what if they're not
oh they need help then yeah you know
what though there are crazy like
homeless people that you could still
tell them like hey you got to go over
there and then don't listen while
they're still talking to themselves so
maybe there's something they can do like
maybe they could be duck feed ear
theaters or something or they could do
something that's like one job and it's
not very hard
yeah yeah we could have him work at the
community center like being a break
dance instructor there was this one
tweet I thought recently I went viral
about it saying that like if people that
were on unemployment that instead of
just receiving checks that they would
actually earn those checks by doing some
sort of like community work so I
disagree with that because it's like if
you're trying to find a job that's a lot
of what consumes a lot of time so if
you're doing community service work how
are you ever gonna find a job again yeah
they should just make laziness illegal
but then I go to jail yes oh why do you
want that because I always think other
people are lazy not me and then I'm
gonna go to jail because I am lazy all
right moving on to the last story here
there was this really really handsome
goat that one yeah what the [ __ ]
trying to [ __ ] this go yeah what's a
handsome girl ones like hey look do you
blame me okay not great it's a long time
right this is go up an actual goat haha
an actual billy goat let me see this
sexy ass go Billy the goat yeah so
there's goat here he's 11 months 11
months he's so handsome he's a William
William please thank you William go oh
he looks like Prince beautiful like he
looks like that kpop star you got beyond
Jesus have like every other go out there
no this is a pretty ask oh yeah
photogenic this fool is he's like a
unicorn go all goats look like that
barber who borrowed this guy's do you
have a little standard the other goats
they're just they're also very pretty
these are like the model go but they all
look like just is this in India this is
in Malaysia Malaysian gold that's
raising them he's in love 21 he said
that when he went to go buy goats this
other human to this other farmer that he
paid 183 US dollars for him without
hesitation as soon as he song because he
was he initially went for a female go
if he needed like goat milk I was in
high demand yeah but now he got go sperm
but then he saw this go and it was you
couldn't resist
there's a kava I want to make you a star
I think I normally go for the ladies but
this one turned me he's gonna be the
first like goat manager monochromator
right go make that into a pun is it go
teacher go yeah
yes well then this he posted photos
others go it on his Facebook and it just
went by room so that code is pretty I
mean to the point where I'm like in love
with the coat the eyes always trip me
the [ __ ] out I've always seen like brown
guts this is the first time I even see
no she likes the brown coat I never did
have appearance or tags yeah a tag to
keep track of bump the track alone but
you know it seemed like a cool like like
he's probably like I'm gonna find the
baddest wife with this but this imagine
you can't even get laid all the girls
just don't want him cuz he's to breed
you're pretty yeah or maybe he's not
pretty in the goat world
he's disgusting the only the gold world
like if I was a human I'd be killing it
like when humans look like monkeys or
turtles or something and it's like man
killing it I love people that look like
monkeys I'm not a lot of turtle people
to people like Asian grapples yeah
there's some people that look like birds
oh yeah true with like some people like
their dogs what a dogs look like Dan do
you if you believe in reincarnation
maybe like we were all those animals in
the past life and then we have traits of
them yeah we still carry traits I like
your wooden there's like a fat guy and
then he has a fat dog and then they walk
- yeah both trying to like work it off
but I have the same hairstyle yeah
that's my mom would refuse to walk our
cocker spaniel when we had one because
it had curly like blonde hair like my
mom she's like [ __ ] no I'm not walking
that looks funny she saw the girl and
then guards us yes
Chihuahua though a Pomeranian I mean
it's still at all because he commented
her hair yeah so they but compared it to
an animal was that a beauty balm Rania's
that beautiful color it's freezing
Pomeranians are like this like frizzy
bumps in the color I was like the cosmic
Auburn we're the ones that have like
really lush like like means whoo oh I
forgot or no a dog Oh dugis collie maybe
the baby's no colles are like oh you're
talking about the one with like the
bangs yeah and it's just so light it's
like a Pantene commercial Afghan
Shepherd the straight ones are the curly
ones straight like where it hangs right
hang cuz if she if he said that no [ __ ]
Ceaser Yorkshire Terriers it's okay it's
like I know which one you're talking
about though it's like the I need one
person to just know where I'm at and
then I'm gonna sleaze just from cartoons
I think it was like in dummy it wonder
whaa ya shins yes just go getting any
like like brand deals now and stuff like
is the faith face of like goat milk now
I was they be not Billy
his name is Ramos oh he's not our almost
it should be Ramone yes do you think out
there they can trade goats for wives
you've been to Malaysia what do you
think I don't know because there are
certain parts of Malaysia that's oh then
maybe like a dowry yeah
oh right i'ma give you a family eight
goats two horses and the [ __ ]
bale of hay I don't know I mean I wonder
you could be worth like five goats I
can't imagine doing that these photos in
a movie laugh cuz I'm like oh and
another thing that's the owner says is
that whenever there's a camera he likes
to poach look like Satan to me a little
bit
oh well cuz they always go down on the
human body they get a go head and then
yeah on a human body or like a goat body
or whatever not this one the upside down
star yeah Nikki Nikki Nikki do you guys
like go curry I like lamb better than go
goats kind of strong the flavor yeah
we're just talking about this beautiful
I know
my ad tastes as good as it looks Oh God
welcome to the brain of I wonder if you
like you know you were saying she
probably has goat sperm now I wonder if
he makes the other goat pretty baby all
[ __ ] I wonder if he eats no like his
children we have to advance all the
pretty goats yeah yeah I wonder why he
has so many white ones oh I guess it's
racist that's what I was thinkin he's
only collecting the white goat you
notice that I did I did it stuck out to
me too I didn't know they were all white
baby he bleaches them right that's
[ __ ] wrong so they're all Michael Jack
we don't like this guy anymore
yeah we hate this guy's was a racist
they said he's 21 he's so young oh my
god
anyone he said that someone came to try
to get Ramos and they're just like nope
but they wanted to buy his ass I would
have sold his ass in a heartbeat he's so
pretty though how could you sell them
does baby oh yeah the bangs are a lot of
things no I kind of wanna like I want to
see different animals like different
dogs like kpop any now well it's that
face app they could do that right the
old people app that's going around they
have like different hairstyles all right
[Music]